what so I asked a serious question that
I'm going to start with okay
very serious how does Ralph pick his
notes with such big fingers that is a
silly question but I will take it
seriously he goes like this there's no
way he get those fingers inside that
nose yeah they're so huge yeah any blows
his nose into his overalls or something
yeah how do you think young people
should deal with their insecurities like
Ralph has well that's a good question
because that's something we really look
at in the movie is like what is it that
makes us feel insecure and Wow why do we
feel insecure I think that it's
important that no matter what makes you
feel insecure that you remember to be
kind to yourself and the things that you
think about yourself because I think
it's very natural for all of us to be to
remember to be kind to the people around
us be kind to our friends that's
something our teachers and our parents
say to us all the time be nice to your
brother be nice to your sister
be kind we have to remember to be nice
to ourselves so when we think about
something that's making us feel insecure
you have to go yes you're nervous about
that you feel insecure about that but
you're gonna be okay
and be a good friend to yourself inside
your own head yeah okay so um how are
you alike very different from your
character well I weigh slightly less
than my character I tend to dress a
little more formally than Ralph but the
things we have in common I like to think
that I have a big heart and I'm a loyal
friend and I'm a protective friend so
you know the size difference Ariana you
could play vanellope and I could
actually play Ralph yeah so if you ever
need like a partner for Halloween or
whatever you could be vanellope and I'll
be Ralph how about that I'm not sure if
I could do the voice bleh I'll try
and okay and here nope can't do it can't
do it that was a big fail but you know
yeah worth a shot yeah so what is your
favorite favorite part about the movie
my favorite part about the movie is that
it tells the truth about friendship
friendship is often really fun and like
makes us feel good and makes us feel
like we have company in the world and
then it's sometimes it's also a struggle
when your friend changes or when you
have an argument or when you don't see
things the same way and I think that the
movie even though it's really fun and
exciting and funny that we try to tell
the truth about you know the work it
takes to be a good friend and what it
means to be a good friend so I hope that
young people like yourself when you go
see the movie you'll think about what it
means to be a good friend every short
time I wonder if there's more to life
than this whoopee or is it wifey it is
new it is different and therefore we
should fear it I'm freaking out hard so
what is your favorite bible video um I
guess any video that includes animals
chant little animals baby person
yeah they can trust animals and babies
yes same with me and baby animals yeah I
love animals and babies and baby too
um how do you like doing voice acting I
really enjoy it it really exercises my
creative muscle because there's no props
there's really no one to interact with
in the room there's no hair there's no
makeup I can't lose myself in wardrobe
and in makeup and like I said you
usually just have a storyboard and maybe
a picture of your character and the rest
is just purely creative you could just
need it to see the other actors when
you're filming um sometimes I did too
they see a couple scenes with john c
reilly
but most times I was in the studio by
myself because of schedules yeah okay so
your character's name is yes so what do
you always always always say yes to
anything sweet especially cobblers all
iMode just anything sweet yes I love
desserts so um how can you relate to
your character I can relate to her
confidence she's very confident she's a
woman who knows what she wants
and she knows how to get what she wants
and she knows how to make a hit and I
love adventures yes she does
I do love adventures yeah that's the
best part and um I would also like to
fight on a like do a big scene on like a
Google like a big Google Tower me too
that sounds really fun that does what I
would like to do the animated version so
that way I know I won't get hurt that's
just like making sure yes holy cow we're
in the Internet isn't that an astute
observation we know that your character
has some insecurities how do you think
that girl should get rid of their
insecurities well you can't really get
rid of your insecurities insecurities
are a part of life and they'll always
touch us in one way or another but as
long as we have perspective like I know
when I look in the mirror I probably am
more critical than anyone else who's
looking at me so I take that on board
and also whenever I see myself in the
mirror I make myself go like this and
you know just know that everyone has
them just know that being in having
insecurities is what makes us human is
what makes us like everyone else and
once you know that then it you don't
feel it so much what do you think you
should tell young girls to do when they
want to do something but their friends
just don't want it do they want to do
something else
oh yeah this is like vanilla pee and
Ralph yeah it's a case-by-case situation
but I think when you want to do
something you gotta go for it and you
can see your friends who want to do
something else another time when you
want to do the same thing it's okay you
don't have to like the same stuff or one
and do the same stuff to be friends so
we know that you have a song in this
movie so when's your album coming out my
album is dropping um no I I don't have
one okay so was it a challenge to come
back to your character six years later
well I missed her so I couldn't wait and
then I thought can I still do the voice
it's all the way up here yeah okay yeah
I didn't do that
and it was fun I missed her it was a
nice reunion I don't think I could ever
tell her Alf there's no law saying best
friends have to have the same dreams
[Music]
I hope you're prepared because there's
gonna be a lot of math and strategies I
have to compliment you on the amazing
sets that were in there and I'd also
like to thank you for putting us in
there oh yeah I was like I know that
place but thank you and the walls were
really great we were very much attention
designer our production designers a guy
named Corey Loftus and he works with
someone named Matias Lechner who has
built these these worlds and just the
imagination of those guys is an endless
and never-ending endless and
never-ending I hope people will go to
this movie and laugh and be wowed by the
way the internet looks and will cry a
little and then what they take away I
hope they'll think oh I've had a fight
with my friend or I've I've had a my
friends have different ideas of what the
world should be or how I should live but
that's okay we can still be friends even
though we don't like exactly the same
things or think exactly the same way and
I think in our world right at this
moment we could use a little more of
that a little more compassion and
empathy yeah I saw a great message like
that in the movie oh good I'm glad you
know and if people go to see the movie
they could always buy the tickets using
this great app or website have you heard
of this one what it's called a fun fun
fun bingo
thank you thank you thank you might want
to try feeding the kitty for a while
bunny
[Music]